that's a smoke detector right well it's
it's rebranded as a musical instrument
and of course you're doing that for what
reason - to avoid the tariffs after
telling Judge Filosa my plan he read
over the tariff laws and told me that my
work was far from done you've gotta
prove to the satisfaction of a court
that this particular thing is accepted
by the general public as a musical
instrument okay
this label proves nothing so how would
you make it accepted by the public if
it's used in a song that people really
not recognize it's a no-no number-one
record or you know one of these singers
I knew that rebranding a smoke detector
would be tough but I never thought I'd
have to create a hit song using one of
the worst noises imaginable and if I was
going to do this I'd need some serious
musical talent so I put up some flyers
announcing open auditions for a new band
and later that week posing as a big-time
record producer I opened my doors to the
best of what la had to offer all right
let's see what you got my man sure don't
look at the clock is deceiving
everything you also dependent on
perceiving the future
fickle motions of your mind us creatures
of the surf Thor was contemplating time
- whoa saddening extreme many of us
travel sheep without Shepherds and none
but but for battle lon rabble the
turnout was better than I expected and
it was clear right away I was drowning
in talent
so after auditioning a drummer named
Chris who could really pound the skins
and yannis a physically attractive
singer who had the right kind of
ambition I mean on a wider perspective
like I want the whole world to hear what
I have to say my band was starting to
take shape
this is freedom to me but I still needed
to figure out which musician was best
suited to playing the smoke detector so
I organized the band's first rehearsal
and after watching them jam it quickly
became clear that the standout talent
was Eddie he was not only the best
musician but also the best showman if
anyone could make the smoke detector
work it was him so after rehearsal was
over I kept Eddie behind to show him his
new instrument I can sing I can play the
drums this is not he's true it is it's a
blue smoke detector yeah this is gonna
be the thing that separates us from any
other band okay and that means the guy
who plays it is gonna be the most famous
you want to be famous don't you um maybe
you do yeah dazzled by the promise of
Fame
Eddie agreed to learn the blue smoke
detector with the help of our
instructional DVD so with that II on
board I spent the next couple days
writing lyrics for what would hopefully
be our breakthrough single and then I
called the band back together to see
what they thought so you know and you
really like a girl but she won't even
look at you in the eye you know he the
song is kind of about that
sorry I'm just a little nervous right
now because it's you know it's personal
and I'm not a the best singer
when I talked to other people about you
I say her in my bed
recipe lo where you once were my lips my
hair my skin my eyes when you left me it
was a big surprise
maybe one day I'll wake up on Jupiter an
entire planet just me and her the band
seemed to like my song
thank you but then Yanni said that he
had a song of his own that he'd been
working on through distance their songs
from nature we distance ourselves from
each other those songs kind of based off
that I like that message I mean we need
to respect like the habit art we live in
[Music]
the song was called orphan skies and
after taking a band vote they liked his
song more and that was great because the
best song won and that's what we wanted
so I told Yanni to teach it to the rest
of the band with one minor adjustment
just so you guys know I took Eddie off
guitar and he's gonna be on smoke
detector for this one smoke detector
SHhhh
I know it's a bit weird but it's really
important that this band has a smoke
detector in it I think it could be the
thing that maybe makes us stand out do
we have to have that one night detector
yes I mean no offense but if you guys
are good enough you should be able to
make it work right
[Music]
I'm not true it's a gift like a little
sister spy
[Music]